we begin this morning with breaking news
overnight and a tragic end to an
hours-long hostage situation at the
nation's largest veterans retirement
home authorities in Napa County
California say the suspect an Army
veteran and three women were found dead
in a room at the facility in Yountville
north of San Francisco the victims
identified as Christine lobe ER dr.
Jennifer Golic and dr. Jennifer Gonzalez
all worked for a nonprofit that helps
veterans of the wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan Carter Evans is in
Yountville Carter good morning good
morning the suspect is identified as
Albert Wong he's a decorated former
infantryman now investigators haven't
released a motive for the attack right
now but reports indicate that Wong had
recently been kicked out of the
treatment program here by one of the
victims napa county sheriff's deputies
were called to the veteran's retirement
home of yan field just after 10:00 a.m.
on Friday investigators say the suspect
albert wong made his way into an
employee party then brandishing an
assault rifle took three women hostage
and started shooting a deputy exchanged
gunfire with the suspect but police had
no more contact with him as he took the
three hostages into a room in one of the
buildings on the sprawling campus he
walked in with a rifle so I think people
had a pretty clear understanding about
what was gonna what was going on there's
obviously no firearms allowed in that
building the home state of lockdown for
nearly eight hours but after failing to
establish contact with wong police made
their move law enforcement personnel
made entry into the room
where we felt the hostages were being
held by the suspect and unfortunately
made the discovery of three deceased
females and one deceased male suspect
military records show Wang was awarded
five medals and a badge for marksmanship
while serving in the Army he spent one
year in Afghanistan during his three
years of active service the three
victims were committed to serving
veterans of Iraq and Afghanistan they
worked for the pathway home a program
that treats vets for post-traumatic
stress disorder in a statement pathway
home said these brave women were
accomplished professionals who dedicated
their careers to serving our nation's
veterans now police are crediting the
first deputy on the scene was stopping
wang from finding more victims there are
security guards here but the association
that represents those guards says
they're not allowed to carry weapons
Anthony Carter Evans in Yountville
California Thank You Carter